-One of those great things
about live television.
James Franco hosted.
There was a scene where he --
There was some blood.
And you --
You actually, like, maybe almost
threw up on live television.
Is that possible?
-Okay.
Let me explain.
-Okay, I didn't know I had a
problem with blood like that.
-Oh, you found out on live TV.
-I found out.
Well, during the rehearsals,
I was just like, "Mm."
You know, 'cause I watch
a lot of bloody stuff,
so I'm like, "Oh, I'll be --"
And all of a sudden,
like -- "Mm. Mm, that's -- Mm.
Ooh, that's making me feel
kind of mm, some kind of way."
You know, I'm like,
"Mm. I can do it."
And Kenan was like,
"Are you gonna be okay?"
"Oh! Mm, I'm fine.
As long as it
don't get on me and stuff,
I think I'll be okay."
James is evil.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-James knew. He knew.
He perfectly timed,
and it went right into my mouth.
-Here's a good shot
at exactly how much --
[ Audience groans ]
Here you are sizing up
exactly what happened.
[ Laughter ]
-Let me tell you,
it went into my mouth.
I immediately threw up
in my mouth.
[ Audience groans ]
But I was in my head,
mentally like,
"You are not about
to throw up on live TV.
You are not gonna do that!
Swallow it!
Swallow it!"
So I was like,
"Ugh! Ugh! Aah, aah, aah!"
-I think that's
this moment right there.
[ Laughter ]
-No, Kenan was laughing so hard,
'cause I was trying
to get off the stage.
I was trying
to get off the stage,
and he just kept pulling me --
"No, no, no!
We got to finish this scene!"
[ Both laugh ]
-I want to ask you --
-Oh, my God.
-One of my favorite things
to do on this show --
we've done it
a couple times now --
"Game of Jones."
-Yes!
-We watch an episode
of "Game of Thrones" together.
"Game of Thrones" has announced
they're not
coming back till 2019.
-Bastards.
-Yeah. Is that --
-You know,
I wrote them so many letters.
-Yeah.
-I was just like --
I was, like, "How dare you
leave me with a blue dragon?!"
[ Laughter ]
"How dare you!"
-Were you an early adopter
of "Game of Thrones."
Did you start watching as soon
as it aired or did you catch up?
-No, I actually
accidentally caught an episode.
I was flipping through the TV,
and I don't know if I caught
Cersei and the dude together.
I don't know what it was,
but I was, like,
"Ooh, this is so interesting."
[ Laughter ]
-If I had told you about the
show and explained it to you,
do you think you would've
thought you would've liked it?
-Yeah.
-Oh, okay.
-As soon as you said dragon,
I would've been, like, "What?"
-Okay, gotcha.
-"Dragons?"
-All right, great.
Well, I'm glad that worked out.
Something that's happening --
-And you know
what's gonna happen
with the blue dragon, right?
-What's gonna happen
with the blue dragon?
-Okay, the dude,
the little young one
that look high all the time.
What is his name?
-Which one?
-The little one
that can't walk no more.
-Oh, yeah, Bran, Bran, yeah.
-Bran!
Bran is going -- he's gonna
take over that dragon.
-Oh, he is.
-'Cause you know
he know how to do the thing.
He know how
to jump into the animal.
So he gonna
see the dragon, go...
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, great.
I can't wait for that.
[ Laughing ]
By the way, Leslie, you're
supposed to say "spoiler alert"
before you ruin stuff.
-Hey, man,
let me tell you something.
I wrecked the -- y'all...
[ Laughter ]
-I know something else
you're excited about
that will be coming before
"Game of Thrones."
You went to the last
Summer Olympics --
-Aah! The Olympics!
Yes, baby!
Slay all day, baby!
Slay all day, USA!
-Do you...
Yeah, give it up
for "Slay all day, USA."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We talking about our athletes!
We talking about
our athletes, baby!
-Are you as excited
about the winter Olympic sports
as you are about summer?
-People are surprised,
but, yes, I like it all.
I like all competition.
I love the ice-skating thing,
even though they don't have
Tonya Harding
and Nancy Kerrigan.
That was way more --
[ Light laughter ]
That was exciting, boy,
when she got hit!
I'm -- I'm -- Okay.
[ Laughter ]
But it was
exciting times, boy.
It was an exciting time.
But they got
a black Jamaican bobsled team.
-Oh, they do.
That's great.
-Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good.
-I'm so excit--
And then -- and then --
What's that event
where they on the skis
and then they just be like...
[ Laughter ]
-Ski jump. The ski jump.
The ski jump.
-That's the one I like.
That's the one I like.
-That's very good.
You'd be very good at that.
-No, I wouldn't.
[ Both laugh ]
-And when you were a kid --
true story --
you were so drawn
to the Olympics
that you destroyed a bathroom
trying to be Nadia Comaneci?
-Yes.
[ Light laughter ]
I was -- Okay,
I probably was like
6 feet tall in the sixth grade.
-Uh-huh.
-I was really tall, so they
wouldn't let me do gymnastics.
They was like, "You're too big."
So I was like, "Well, I need
to prove you wrong," you know?
"And I need
to prove my dad wrong,"
'cause my dad wanted me
to be a basketball player.
So I was like,
"All of y'all are just wrong."
[ Laughter ]
So, in my bathroom,
there's the shower-rod thing.
-Yeah.
-You know, shower rod and, uh...
I said, um, "It's time."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You know?
-An athlete knows.
-An athlete knows
when it's time to take it on.
You know?
[ Laughter ]
So I got some baby powder,
which is a little bit
more slipperier than the chalk
they actually use.
-Yep, sure.
Looks the same.
-It looks the same though, so...
And I even did the introduction.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I'm saying?
And I got on there,
and I just, "Hoo!
Hoo!
And just
tore the whole wall out.
[ Laughter and applause ]
The whole...
Ceramic...
Yo, I just --
[ Laughs ]
I remember
my mom said, "Why?!
Why would you do this?!"
And my dad just laughed.
-Oh, well, that's good.
-Yeah, my dad just laughed.
-That's a nice combo.
Good to have one of each.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Always so great to see you.
Can't wait for Saturday.
-You, too, baby, yes!
-And, yeah,
it will be great to see.
Hopefully you're playing
a president next time I see you.
-Yay!
-Leslie Jones, everybody!